m
[Musique]
ce lundi 26 février la réunion a
officiellement inauguré son village de
600 mètres carrés au salon de
l'agriculture à paris
c'est avec fierté que le président du
département cyrille melchior a félicité
les exposants et le travail accompli
entouré de l'ensemble des partenaires
cette année la réunion les pierrot
présenté au salon art et culture les
stalles forment une belle vitrine et
c'est là que nous montrons ce que la
réunion a de meilleur et c'est là aussi
que nous invitons les personnes qui
passent ici à venir nous rendre visite
et donc c'est une façon aussi de pousser
au développement touristique de la
réunion
victor hugo disait qu'un homme heureux
c'est celui qui assurons de notre homme
heureux et je peux vous assurer qu
aujourd'hui quand je vois large sourire
des exposants sur ses 600 m² dont je voi
enthousiasme qui a dans ce village
réunion oui je suis un homme comblé un
homme heureux
la sénatrice nassimah dindar était
également présente encore président du
département il ya quelques mois ce
village est aussi le fruit de son
travail
c'était une initiative voulue par
l'ensemble des partenaires le vice
président maire de la petite île qui
avec moi l'année dernière et avec les
agriculteurs présents et le président de
la chambre s'était dit il nous fallait
une meilleure vitrine pour représenter
l'ensemble des savoir faire
j'ai envie de dire aussi de savoir est
que nous avons chez nous à l'île de la
réunion et c'est un beau succès
public répond présent une ambiance
festive sur le village et des exposants
heureux de pouvoir remercier ceux qui
leur ont permis d'être l'un c'est quand
même la première fois qu'on a une espace
comme ça et qu'on ne paye pas notre
stand
donc bravo bravo et encore bravo
c'est grâce et à l'heure
de mentir à leur travail que nous on est
en artisans exposants on peut on peut se
permettre d'être d'un salon de
l'agriculture parce que sinon les coûts
les cours auraient été fait et ce train
pour était trop fort et personnellement
pour répète là c'est une aubaine je dis
merci
ce nous c'est la première fois qu'on
participe à ce salon
sans nos élus on n'aurait pas plu à 3
notre salle on notera poisse rester à la
réunion
parmi les nombreux passants nous
retrouvons des visages familiers des
réunionnais venus la veille à la
boutique de la réunion ou des tickets
d'entrée pour le salon leur avait été
offert super franchement c'est mieux que
l'année dernière parce que moi je viens
pratiquement tous les ans mais là
là nous les vraiment lire c'est la
première fois que je viens
salamatou question
et là j'ai découvert vraiment quelque
chose d'extraordinaire surtout sur l'île
de la réunion est magnifique et là j'ai
acheté saucisses comme mon fils dans
c'est le seul moyen de récupérer les
bons saucisse de la réunion une journée
qui s'est achevée par la désignation
d'une nouvelle ambassadrice qui l'iran
gamin participant à l'émission top chef
en 2010 est ambassadrice et déjà un
grand nom ils peuvent alors que je
l'assimilé que je comprenne vraiment la
grande définition mais déjà toute une
fierté et je pense que c'est une
reconnaissance pour tout ce travail
accompli on va essayer de travailler de
mettre en avant et de mettre encore en
l'air et plus haut la réunion les
produits locaux qu'à profonde
[Musique]